I want to take up in Volume 17, in July 25, 1924, and the heading says that the divine
will keep searching for souls who would lose all their rights, so that the divine will
might continue its divine act by placing all souls in their arms as it did with Jesus
on the cross. This is a very important section. So, Louisa says that this morning my sweet
Jesus made himself seen in my interior in the act of stretching his arms out in the
shape of a cross. "And I remain stretched with him," she said. "And then Jesus said
my daughter, 'The last act of my life was to lay myself on the cross and to stay there
until I died.' With my arms opened, unable to move or to oppose what the executioners
were doing to me." I was the true portrait, the living image of one who lives not in the
human will but in the divine. So, there goes all our romantic images of being flying high
and really having a good time that the true image of living in the divine will is the
crucified image of Jesus on the cross. Being unable to move or to oppose myself, having
lost every right over myself because it was taken from him, the horrible tension that
was in my arms, how many things they said. And while I was losing my rights, others acquired
my life. Now that's the essential piece there that the person living in the divine will
is living sacrificial love so that others may rise from the dead and live in God's presence.
So Jesus said that as he was losing his rights over himself, others acquired his life. The
first right was that of the supreme will which using its immensity and all-seeingness gathered
all souls, innocent and sinful, good and holy and placed them in my outstretched arm. So,
here you've got the fulfillment of John chapter 10, 'I am the good shepherd and I lay down
my life from my sheep.' And then in the same chapter, Jesus says, 'The Father loves me
because I will lay down my life.' Now the Father loved Jesus infinitely, absolutely
unconditionally, eternally, anyway. So that text is saying that the Father had a very special
love for Jesus because he sacrificed himself to give life to us. So it's all about sacrificial
love. And until we get the message that it is all about sacrificial love, it's all about
love, that is divine love, that's agape, and it's all about sacrificial love. That divine
love is sacrificial. It gives of itself to give life to others. So Jesus said that in
his wide open arms, all souls, good and bad, were placed in his outstretched arms so that
he might bring them to heaven. So there you have this wonderful, wonderful image of Jesus
as the great bridge, the Pontifex mactimus, and he hanging over the abyss and the people
of God walking triumphantly over his shoulders into heaven. Anything we achieve spiritually
is through him, with him, and in him, we are nothing of ourselves. Jesus said, 'I refused
no one, so this is love without borders.' I'm saying that slowly to make sure you hear
it, love without borders. We don't ask whether the people believe or don't believe if they're
in a good religion or a bad religion, if they're atheists or believers or whatever, we don't
ask anything. We simply place all souls in the arms of Jesus. He said, 'I refused no
one, so this is love without borders.' So the divine will gave a place to everyone in
my arms, so all souls were placed in Jesus. He's the one who determines what happens to
them eternally. Now the supreme will, sorry, now, the supreme will is a continuous act
never interrupted. And what the divine will does once, it never ceases doing. And even
though my humanity is in heaven and is not subject to suffering now, it keeps searching
for souls who do not move in the human will, but in the divine, and who oppose nothing.
Souls who would lose all their rights so that the right being holy of the divine will,
the divine will would continue its act of placing all souls, sinners and saints, innocent
and wicked in the arms of the one who offers to lay herself in my will, in order to repeat
and continue what my arms did outstretched on the cross. There you've got something
absolutely divine, and that is that Jesus wants us to be a perfect replica of himself.
And he is looking for those souls who will surrender all of their own rights, become
a crucified love, small l, as he was the crucified love, all capital letters. And we
become a tiny mirror image of him so that he can place all souls in our care as well.
So he said the divine will wants to place all souls, the sinners and saints, innocent
and wicked in the arms of the one who offers to lay herself in my will, in order to repeat
and to continue what my arms did outstretched on the cross. This is why I have laid myself
within you, Jesus said to Louisa, so that the Supreme will may continue its act of bringing
everyone into my arms in you and through you. So now Jesus talks about what sanctity really
is.
Sanctity he said is not formed by one single act. If you want to make a cardigan or a jumper,
you cannot make it with one stitch. The one stitch has no likeness at all to the jumper.
You need thousands of stitches put together in a particular pattern and in a particular
way to get this beautiful garment. So the garment of sanctity is woven by many thousands
and thousands and thousands of acts. Sanctity is not formed by one single act, but by many
acts united together like putting your jumper together. One act by itself forms neither sanctity
nor perversity because since the continuation of the acts is missing, the colors and the
living shades of sanctity are missing. Do you remember that old saying that we got
remember children? So an act, reap a habit, sow a habit, reap a character, sow a character,
reap a destiny. But you must begin by sowing the acts. As I shared with somebody only today,
if you sow one potato seed in your garden, you're not expecting a field of potatoes.
Paul is quite clear about that in two Corinthians when he says that you reap what you sow and
you also reap in the measure that you sow. So if there aren't continuous acts in the
divine will, then the colors and the living shades of sanctity are missing. And because
these are missing, one cannot attribute a just weight and value either to sanctity or
to perversity. One bad act doesn't make an evil person. One good act doesn't make a saint.
So, what makes sanctity shine and places the seal on it are the continuous good acts. These
are the continuous acts in the divine will. No one can say he is rich because he possesses
one coin. But those who possess extensive properties, villas, palaces, et cetera, et cetera and
a huge bank book, they can say they're rich. So it is for sanctity as well. And if sanctity
needs many good acts, many sacrifices, much heroism, but can also be subject to gaps to
intervals and so on, the sanctity in my will is not subject to intermittent phases. Once
we get to the place of putting our will permanently in the divine will, that's it. We're clicked
into the eternal will permanently. That's just the way it is. We're not going back to
the human will. Up to that moment, we are simply going in and out of the divine will.
But we have not reached this wonderful place where our will has finally and totally said
fiyat miki sakondam verabam tuam. Be it done unto me according to your word. We've not
really passed the test of being children of Mary yet. So Jesus said the sanctity of my
will is not subject to intermittent phases, but must associate itself with the continuous
act of the eternal volition, which never, never ceases, but is always acting, always
operating, always triumphant, which always loves and never stops. Now here's a little
bit of discernment for you that you can find out where you're at in the divine will because
if your love stops or if you make an excuse that you know you don't have to love that
particular person or love in that particular situation, these are the gaps which tell you
that your will has not finally clicked into the divine will. So the sanctity in my will
brings into the soul the mark of the operating or the work of our creator. So the sanctity
in the divine will actually portrays to other people, they can see it quite clearly, that
this is the mark of the work of the creator. This isn't the work of a creature. And that
is it's his continuous love. It's his continuous preservation of all things created by him.
He never changes. He is immutable. This is what is declared in heaven in the book of Revelation
chapter four and verse eight. The God who is who was and who is to come. The eternal one.
The God who said, "Aego, Amy, I am." There was nothing else to say. That's it, complete.
Who is subject to changing belongs to the earth. That's the low place, not to heaven.
That's the high place. Changing is of the human will, not the divine. Interrupting good
is of the creature, the low place, the human will. It's not of the creator. Therefore,
all this would be on be fitting for the sanctity of living in my will because it contained because
the sanctity in the divine will contains the insendia, the image of the sanctity of the
creator. Imagine we can be a tiny miniature of the sanctity of the creator. The mind buckles.
It's fantastic. Therefore, be attentive. Leave all rights to the Supreme will. And Jesus
said, "I will keep forming in you the sanctity of living in the divine will." This is something
that goes on 24/7, 365. It goes on all the time. It doesn't break. It doesn't stop just
because you're sleeping. That's very important. That's why it's so important to fuse into
the divine will and offer your sleep to the Lord so that everything in your entire day
is his. And we start getting used to the idea that the divine will has taken over.
So since the emphasis has been on acts, we now go into July the 29th, 1924, in which the
acts done in the divine will form a prop on which Jesus and the soul can both take rest.
This morning, after much struggling, Louisa said, "Jesus came and was seen in her interior."
Now, that's Luke 17, 21. And it's also one Corinthians 3, 16. "No, you, not that you
are the temple of the living God and that the Spirit of God dwells in you." So he showed
himself tired as if he wanted to rest. And since there was some kind of a prop within
me, he extended his arms to cling to that prop and placing his head on it, he rested.
And not only did he rest, but he invited me to rest with him. So if you go to Matthew
11, 28, the 30, Jesus invites us all to rest in him and with him. How enjoyable it was,
she said, to be leaning on that prop together with Jesus to take a little rest after so much
bitterness. Then afterwards, he said to me, "My daughter, do you want to know what this
prop is?" Which relieves us so much and gives us rest, it's all your acts done in the divine
will. Therefore, if the prop is fit to be leaned on, we've got to do many, many, many
acts in the divine will. It's all your acts done in my will that formed this prop for
me and for you, which is so strong as to be able to sustain the weight of heaven and
earth, which I contain within me and to give me rest. "My will alone contains this strength
and this virtue, which is so great. The acts done in my will bind heaven and earth and
in close within themselves, the divine power, such as to be able to sustain God himself."
Let me read that for you again. "The acts done in my will bind heaven and earth." There's
great power in this kind of prayer. And these acts in close within themselves, the divine
power, that's why they're so effective. They're even able to sustain God himself.
On hearing this, Louisa said to him, "My love, yet with all this prop you are talking
about, I fear that you may leave me. What shall I do without you? And you know how miserable
and good for nothing that I am. So I fear that as you leave me, your will may depart
as well." And Jesus said, "My daughter, why do you fear? I want to give you one John
for eighteen, perfect love casts out fear." And look how high Louisa is in her relationship
with God, and she's still pestered by this fear that he might actually leave her. Jesus
said, "This fear is your human will which would want to enter the field to take a few
steps. My will excludes every fear because it has nothing to fear. It has nothing to
fear. Naturally, it's sovereign. On the contrary, my will is confident of itself and it is unshakeable.
And more. You must know that as the soul decides to let herself be possessed by my will and
to live in it, since my will is linked with all created things and there's nothing over
which it does not have its dominion, in the same way, the soul remains linked with all
created things. And as she does her acts, her daughtership with my will, her dwelling,
her possession, remain inscribed on all created things with indelible characters." Now, this
really, really needs to be looked at line by line, word by word. I want to give you Romans
eight nineteen because Jesus is describing those wonderful sons of God that the whole
earth is crying out for so that the entire earth can recover as well. Look at the whole
university said, "Your name, your daughtership with my will is written with indelible characters
in the heavens, in the stars, in the sun, in everything." Because she's been praying
her divine acts and doing her rounds, including all of creation. So, how can it ever be possible
that this eternal and divine mother may leave her dear daughter born of her and raised with
so much love? Therefore, remove every fear if you do not want to ambit her may and Jesus
suffers enough from all the evil that goes on on the earth. And while he was saying this,
Louisa looked into the heavens and into the sun and to all the rest and she could see
her name written with the title of daughter of the divine will. May everything she said
be for the glory of God. This reminds me of an incident in St. Therese's life when she
was walking with her father and she looked up and she saw tea in the sky, tea for Therese.
One day I was walking and talking to the Lord and I said, "I bet anything my name isn't
written in the sky." I understand Louisa seeing her name into great things and I understand
Therese seeing tea in the sky and with the marvelous humor with which the Lord has dealt
with me all my life, he said, "No, your name's in the gutter." And I looked down and there
at my feet was a fire hydrant with the two letters F-H and I just laughed. And ever since
I've said to him, "I know I'm one of the ones that have to live in the gutter. I have
to live in the nothing because I don't have a chance at all if I don't stay in the nothing.
So I don't mind it at all and I don't even mind walking over the fire hydrant and putting
my foot on the F-H. I don't mind at all." So some people see their names or their letter
in the sky and some of us are from a much more lowly place altogether.
So August the 9th, 1924, "Praying, suffering and working in the divine will are the only
embankment for divine justice." Now this is terribly important as I speak to you in
the middle of the coronavirus crisis. The only thing to hold back the hand of justice
is prayer, suffering and working in the divine will. After much waiting for the presence
of my adorable Jesus, Louisa said, "I felt him in my interior." That again is your Luke
17, 21 and 1 Corinthians 3, 16. "I felt him in my interior extending his arms and saying
to me, 'My daughter, extend your arms together with me in my will.' Everything we do, literally
everything is to be done in His will. In order to repair for many who extend their works
in the human will, which forms for them a net of all evils to hurl them into the eternal
abyss. And also to do this, that is, extend your arms together with Jesus in His will
to prevent His justice from pouring itself out on them." So there's two things that
were to do, that's one and this is two. One is to make reparation for all the actions
in the human will that's leading people to the abyss. And the second one is to prevent
the divine justice from pouring itself on these people operating in the human will in
order to vent its fury. In fact, when the creature extends herself in my will to operate
and to suffer, my justice feels touched by the creature with the power of my will and
it ceases its just rigors. Now, you really need to take that on board. Look at the power
that Jesus says He gives to us when we pray in the divine will. That divine justice will
actually cease its rigors. So please don't think that your prayers are just not having
an effect. It is a divine vein that the creature makes flow between God and the human family
and because of this divine vein, which His justice cannot help but having regard for
poor humanity. So in doing our acts in the divine will, this forms this wonderful connection
between heaven and earth. So I want to give you John 1.51 there, the ladder between heaven
and earth in which divine justice holds back because these wonderful divine acts of love
and honor and gratitude and reparation and all the rest are coming from the earth. And
while saying this, Jesus showed how creatures are preparing a great revolution among parties
against the government and against the church. Now, Louisa, it gets, this is 1924 and Louisa
is given information as all the prophets are of things that are about to happen in the
future if human beings don't turn around and do God's will. So a great revolution among
parties against the government and against the church. What a horrible massacre could
be seen, how many tragedies, and then my sweet Jesus resumed talking. My daughter, he said,
did you see, creatures don't want to stop. Their greed for shedding blood is not yet
quenched in them. And this greed for blood provokes the divine justice to destroy entire
cities by earthquakes, by water that's tsunamis and by fire. Now, in recent times, we've had
a lot of testing by fire in America and in Australia to take just two examples. And so
the divine justice will want to make the inhabitants of these cities disappear from the face of
the earth. In other words, a lot of death. Therefore, my daughter, pray, suffer, operate
in my will, because this alone can be an embankment so that my justice may not burst out with
this devastating thunderbolts to destroy the whole earth. So when we do our acts in the
divine will, it's like you've put your hand in the hole in the wall that stops the wall,
the ocean from coming in and flooding the city. So I want to give you Leviticus 10 verses
1 to 3 and verses 4 to 7. Then Jesus continued, "Oh, if you knew how beautiful and how delightful
it is to see a soul operate in my will. An image of this can be seen to you by Father
see and Mother earth, which are so bound and linked to each other that the water cannot
be without the earth and the earth would be sterile without the water. There is like
a marriage between them such that the sea can be called Father and the earth Mother,
because she receives the sea, such is the union which the soul should have in my will.
So for a reflection on this, I suggest to go to the book of Job 38 verses 8 to 11. So
is going to give us an example of Father see in the next paragraph and then the following
one is going to give us an example of Mother earth. Now, what is there in the sea? So this
is Father see, an immensity of waters. Who inhabits these waters? Who do they nourish?
Now notice anything that God does gives life. To whom do they give life? It is to many different
fish. Or many different, we would say in English, types of fishes, types of fish. See, this
is a translation from another language. So it says fishes, but fishes can be all one
species with many different types of fish, which nourish themselves swim and dart inside
the immense sea. See then, the sea is one entity, one unit, one reality, but many types
of fish actually live in it. So it's able to sustain much life. I want to put many types
of fish. However, the love and the jealousy of the sea towards the fish is so great that
it keeps them hidden within itself. And that's the divine will wants to do with us is to
enable us to live a hidden life inside of the divine will. Its waters lay themselves above
and below the fish to the right and to the left. If the fish want to swim and move, it
slices through the waters and darting it enjoys itself. And the water lets itself be caught
through, but it presses itself around around the fish above and below. It never leaves
it. Now that's a very important point, because that's the point that Jesus has been making
to Louisa all the time that a matter of what is going on between her and the Lord. The
one thing that never happens is that he would actually leave her. That would be an impossibility
as far as he's concerned. So the fish, the water never leaves the fish. And therefore
the fish passes it immediately closes the way behind it leaving no trace of where it passes
or where it reaches. Now notice the hiddenness there. So that no one may follow it. So you're
totally safe inside of the divine will swimming in the immense sea of the divine will. If the
fish wants to be nourished, if the fish wants to be nourished, the water offers itself to
feed it. If the fish wants to sleep, the water makes itself its bed, but it never leaves
it. The water always presses itself around the fish. But in spite of this, one can see
that in the sea there are beings which are not the waters. You can still notice the difference
in the reality between the water and the fish. That's also in the divine will. We may be
swimming deep in the heart of the sea of the divine will, but we're still just creatures
in the divine will. One can see that in the sea there are beings which are not water.
One can see motions, darts formed by these mutant habitants for which the sea is the
life while they are the glory, the honor and the richness of the sea. So much more, much,
much more than fish is the soul who operates and lives in my will. My will is immense,
the creature is finite. However, she has her motions, her voice and her walking. And as
my will sees her within itself, its love and jealousy are so great, it's much more than
the sea. It lays itself above and below her to the right and to the left. It makes itself
her life, her food, her word, her work, her step, her suffering, her bed, her rest, her
dwelling for this fortunate creature. In other words, he is our everything. I remember once
doing a little exercise with the Lord. He didn't need it. I was the one who needed it.
I said, Lord, I am poverty. He said, I am plenty. I said, I am hungry. He said, I am
your food. I said, I am sick. He said, I am your health. I said, I am a sinner. He said,
I am your savior. And I went on and on and on. And whatever I said, he was the solution.
And I finished with the words of John the Baptist, I am the I am not. He said, I am.
So the I am not finds its full and complete life and its completeness when it goes into
the I am. So that's the fish in the sea. I think it's fantastic. So the divine will follows
the soul everywhere. It even enjoys itself together with her. Now that's Proverbs 831.
The Lord delights to be with the children of men and loves playing with them. It's not
our image of God that we were given as children. Jesus said, I could say that these souls are
my glory, my honor and the richness to whom my will gives birth. The working of the soul
in my will is like the swimming and the darting of the fish in the terrestrial sea. But the
soul does it in the celestial sea of the supreme volition. In other words, we're actually swimming
in the heart of the Trinity, therefore in the heart of God, therefore in the heart of
heaven, therefore in the eternal one, therefore in eternity. So you're living heaven on earth
now. The only difference between heaven and earth for someone in the divine will is that
we have the suffering side here on earth and the glory side in heaven. These souls are
the hidden inhabitants of the celestial waves. Now notice the emphasis on hidden life. You
see people living at the ordinary level, or should I say the level of ordinary spirituality
in the church. They manifest their love for God and their love for their neighbor by external
works. People living in the divine will have shifted completely and we live the hidden
life of Christ on the earth. And so we live hidden with Christ in God. Now that's exactly
what St. Paul speaks about as well. I've only just, that's only just come to my head
just now, hidden with Christ in God. So what St. Paul said there, he wouldn't have known
the fullness of, and that's typical of any of the writers in the Bible, that there's
two authors. One is the human and the other is the divine. And the human author is often
led by the divine author to say something that he himself doesn't know the fullness
of simply because God is going to reveal himself more and more and more. And so future generations
will understand much more deeply than we understand and we understand much more deeply than the
generations that have gone before us. That's the way it is. So we live a life hidden with
Christ in God. So these souls are the hidden inhabitants of the celestial waves. Who live
from the immense inheritance, live out of, I should say. They live out of the immense
inheritance of the infinite sea of my will. And just as the fish are hidden disappeared
inside the sea, they are mute. Yet they form the glory of the sea and they serve as food
for man. So in the same way, do these souls seem disappeared? In other words, we're not
out there on the big stage. We're not going on all these processions. We're not doing
all these big projects. They seem disappeared inside of the divine sea. They are mute. Now
please take that on board. They are mute. They're silent. Yet they form the greatest
glory of creation. And they are the primary calls for my letting descend upon the earth,
the delicious food of my will and my grace. Now we've moved on. And so we must realize
that there's no external rasimatas. There's no big projects that we're doing that we get
ourselves, we dive into the sea of the divine will. We stay there, hidden, silent, letting
the divine will do what it wants in us and through us. So now we come to the second example
that Jesus wanted to give and its mother earth. Another image of operating of the soul in
my will is the earth. The souls who live in my will are the plants, the flowers, the trees
and the seeds. With how much love does the earth not open in order to receive the seed?
Mother, it does not open its splits in order to place itself upon it and to help the seed
to become dust with itself so as to be able to deliver more easily from its womb the plant
which the seed contains. And as it begins to come out of its womb, it presses itself,
the earth presses itself around it. It gives it the humours it contains almost like food
to make it grow. A mother couldn't be more affectionate as mother earth. In fact, a mother
does not always hold her newborn on her lap. Nor does she constantly give him milk, while
the earth more than a mother never detaches from the plant, the plant from her breast.
Rather, the more it grows at the top, the more the earth sinks beneath and it rips open to
make space for its roots so as to let the plant grow more beautiful and strong. Its love
and its jealousy are so great that it keeps it attached to its breast to give it life
and continuous nourishment. Now notice the example of the sea, the water kept on taking
care of the fish and in the example of the earth, the earth continues without ever stopping
to take care of the plant. So both of these are images of the soul in the divine will
where the Lord never ever stops taking care of that soul. But the plants and the flowers
are the most beautiful ornament of the earth. They are its happiness, its glory and its
richness and they provide food for the human generations. Because anything that comes out
of the Lord gives life to others. So more than mother earth, Jesus said, is my will,
for the soul who lives and operates in my will. More than a tender mother, I hide her
in my will. I help her to let the seed of her will die. Notice the seed of her will.
Very important. As the seed of the human will must die, that she may be reborn in mine.
Now there you have the emphasis on when we truly enter into the divine will, we are reborn
to a completely new life. Everything will be different. Absolutely everything will be
different. I nourish her with the celestial milk of my divinity. My jealousy is such
that I keep her attached to my breast and I remain pressed around her that she may grow
beautiful and strong in all, all in my likeness. So it's hidden with Christ in God and we
become a whole new creation in Him, as Paul says. Therefore, my daughter, be attentive,
always operate in my will if you want to make your beloved Jesus content. I would like you
to stop everything and to take this point of living and operating constantly in my will.
There you have it. The Lord wants us to stop and I'm saying this when the whole nation
has stopped and we've given ourselves two weeks in order to try and get control of this
coronavirus. He says to stop and to take this point alone and to go with that, to allow
ourselves to be completely immersed in the divine will so that the divine will can give
us a new birth from the womb of God and can bring us to live a celestial life on earth.
So August the 14th, 1924. The delight of Jesus when the soul, like a little wheel, goes around
constantly in the divine will. The operating of the divine will contains the creative power.
So Louisa said, I was thinking to myself, I would like to always go around in the divine
will. I'd like to be like a little wheel, like the wheel of a clock that always rotates
without ever stopping. But while I was thinking of this, my Jesus moved in my interior and
said, my daughter, do you want always to go around in my will? That's exactly what he
wants. Oh, how gladly and with what love do I want you to go around constantly in my will?
Now notice that when a thought comes to us and we think it's our own, he in fact has
actually given it to us. Your soul will be the little wheel. My will will wind you. So
he's thinking of the clock as well to make you rotate rapidly without ever stopping. Your
intention will be the starting point of where you want to go. So here we have the reminder
that placing the intention is very important no matter what you're doing in the divine
will. Whatever way you take, you want to take, whether it's in the past, the present
or the future, it's your free choice. You will always be dear to me and you will give
me the greatest delight, whatever starting point you choose. So sometimes we tell him,
no, I want to go and do some work in purgatory. I want to go and work with the dying or with
sinners who are rebelling against you or whatever it is. He doesn't mind where you start so
long as you go. Then Jesus added, dearest daughter of my will, the operating of my will
contains the creative power. Now he's been trying to tell us this for quite a number
of volumes. See, everything my humanity did while on earth, because everything was done
in the supreme will, everything contains this creative power. So everything was done in
the divine will, so much so that just as the sun is always an act, always full of light
and heat without ever decreasing or increasing in its full splendor, just as it was created
by God in the same way, everything I did is in act. That means that all of these acts
are eternal and God lives in the eternal now. God doesn't live in the past and God doesn't
live in the future. He said, I am. He lives in the eternal now. So when we enter into
the divine will, we go outside of time and space and into eternity, where there's neither
past nor future. That's why we can pray for everybody from Adam to Zachary. So therefore,
because all the acts of Jesus in his life are divine acts and they are available eternally.
So that means that we can enter into any of them any time we like and as far as he's concerned,
it's the same as if you had been there 2,000 years ago. So I can join him now in his agony
in the guard. I remember one time in a crisis asking the Lord, what should I do? And he said
very simply, come, kneel in front of me. I mean, literally with his body over mine, he
said, put your hands in mine and together put your agony with my agony. And together,
we will do it. We'll do what we have to do. So he said, my agony will redeem yours. And
together, we will look after the souls that need to be looked after. I was thinking of
particular souls. And so he just said, we look after the souls you want. So everything
that Jesus did in his lifetime is in act and available to us. That's why the priest
only has to say, this is my body and this is my blood to join Jesus at the last supper.
And it is, in fact, Jesus still pronouncing the same words. And that's why we say that
the priest is in persona, Christie, in the person of Christ, and that eternal act is
being pronounced again and again and again and again over us. So Jesus said, everything
I did is all in act. And just as the sun belongs to everyone, to all and to each one, in the
same way, in my operating, while being one, it belongs to all and to each one. So everything
that Jesus did and said is for everybody and for you and I as individuals as well. Even
more, he said, my thoughts form a circle around each created intelligence. My gazes, my words,
my works, my steps, my heart beats, my pains, they all form a circle around the gazes, words,
works, and pains, et cetera, of creatures. So everything in him forms a circle around
us and we can enter into that. And if you're worried about the way somebody is thinking,
just enter into that divine intelligence and let that divine intelligence cover the intelligence
of the person you're praying for so that they can be disposed to thinking the way God
thinks and all the rest. Jesus said, I could say that like a circle, I guard all that the
creature does. Now, if the creature thinks in my will, the circle of my thought opens
and encloses her thoughts in mine. And so taking part in the creative power, her thoughts
perform the office of my intelligence before God and before creatures. It's mind-boggling.
In the same way, if you look, if you speak, my gazes, my words form the place in which
to receive yours and to form one single circle. It's quite literally Jesus in me and I in
him. They perform the office of my gazes and of my works. And so with all the rest. So
the souls who live in my will are my true repeaters, my inseparable images. Now, this,
I think, is absolutely fascinating. Up to now, we've had Jesus in the early books, early
volumes, we had Jesus refer to only to his mother as my inseparable mother. Then you
get up to volume 11 and 12, and it's my inseparable Louisa. Now here he's talking about in volume
17 that you and I have to be inseparable with him as well. So if our blessed mother
is inseparable with Jesus and I am inseparable with Jesus, then I am inseparable with her.
It's totally fascinating, amazing, hard to take on board. The souls who live in my will
are my true repeaters. In other words, we repeat his life. They are my inseparable images
which are portrayed in them and absorbed again in me so that everything they do may remain
with the seal, that those are my works as they continue my own very office. So I want
to give you John 1412. So in this context of the enormity of the privilege that is given
to us, the next message puts in a very important correction into the system and that is that
if we distrust him, it is a terrible insult. So September 2nd, 1924, how much harm distrust
causes the soul. So Louisa said, I was feeling very oppressed but all abandoned in the arms
of Jesus and I prayed him to have compassion on me. But while I was doing this, I felt
I was losing consciousness and I saw a little girl. She was weak, pale and all engrossed
and deep melancholy coming out from within me. And blessed Jesus going towards her, took
her in his arms and moved to pity, pressed her to his heart. And with his hands, he touched
her forehead, making her eyes, her lips, her breasts and all the members of the little
girl marking them with the sign of the cross. And as he was doing this, she would regain
strength, acquire color and stir herself from that state of melancholy. And Jesus seeing
that the little girl was reacquiring strength would clasp her more tightly to himself to
strengthen her more. And he said to her, poor little one, what a state you are in. But don't
fear your Jesus will make you come out of this state.
So while this was happening, Louisa thought, who is this little girl that came out from
me that Jesus loves so much? And Jesus said, my daughter, this is your soul. And I love
her so much that I cannot tolerate seeing you so melancholic and weak. This is why I've
come to infuse new life and new vigor into you. Now there it has been handed to you on
a plate. If you're feeling down, discouraged, and all the rest of it, you simply ask the
Lord to infuse new life and new vigor into you.
On hearing this, Louisa said, my love and my life, Jesus, how I fear that you might leave
me? How shall I go on without you? How should I be able to live? To what a deplorable state
will my poor soul be reduced? What a harrowing pain is the thought that you might leave me.
A pain that lacerates me takes peace away from me and puts hell in my heart. Jesus have
pity, compassion, have mercy on me, a little child. That's Matthew 18 verses 1 to 3.
I have no one, she said, if you leave me, everything is over for me. And Jesus, resuming
his speech added, my daughter, Cam yourself, do not fear your Jesus does not leave you.
I'm jealous of your trust. And I do not want you to even slightly distrust me. So now he's
going to talk about the importance of confidence in God. And I want to remind you that Saint
Therese of this, you said that you will receive from God exactly as much as you trust him
for no more, no less. We must trust him beyond reason. That is something the Lord told me
nearly 10 years ago to tell everybody I ever came in contact with that times were going
to become more and more challenging. And that, you know, there's panic out in the world
at the moment because of the coronavirus and that lots of things would happen. But we were
to trust him beyond reason. We were not to listen to the world. We're to listen to him.
So Jesus said, I love the souls. I love so much that souls be with me in full trust that
many times I hide some defect or imperfection of theirs or some lack of correspondence to
my grace. So as not to give them any occasion not to come back in full trust. That's a bit
like the parent won't say a solitary word about the little girl who has caught her dress
or her blouse or whatever else because they want the child to come back in full trust
to them. In fact, if the soul loses trust, she remains as though separated from me and
all huddled up within herself. Well, that's not going to achieve anything. She places
herself at due distance from me and remains paralyzed in her surge of love and therefore
paralyzed and sacrificing herself for me. Oh, how much harm does distrust cause? It can
be said that it is like the spring frost that blocks the vegetation of the plants. And many
times if the frost is strong, it can even make them die. In the same way, distrust blocks
the development of virtue and puts freezing cold into the most ardent love. Oh, how many
times because of lack of trust, my designs and the greatest sanctities have been blocked.
What a tragedy, just for lack of trust. This is why I tolerate some defects rather than
distrust because those can never be so harmful. Isn't that amazing? Your faults and failings
don't do as much damage at all as not trusting the Lord. And besides, how can I leave you
if I've worked so much in your soul? Take a look at how much I had to work. And while
saying this, he showed assumptions and great palace worked by the hands of Jesus in the
depths of my soul. And then he resumed speaking. I want to give you Ephesians 210 for that
where God's work of art. He said, my daughter, how can I leave you? Take a look at how many
rooms John 14 and two in my father's house. There are many rooms. They're almost innumerable.
In other words, he has expanded her soul in an incredible way. Look, as much knowledge,
look at the effects, the values, the qualities that I have made known to you in my will and
so many rooms with each one of these I have formed in you in which to deposit all these
goods. In other words, as the Lord gives us more, he has to expand us more to be able
to receive it. It's nothing left but to add some more varieties of some different colors
in order to portray more rare beauties of my supreme will. To give more prominence and
honor to my work. And you feared that I might leave such a great crafting of mine. It costs
me too much. There is my will involved in it, he said, and where my will is, there is life.
And life is not subject to death. Anyway, he says, your fear is nothing but a little
bit of distrust on your part. Wow. So now she has the self revelation she actually needed,
that she the little bit of distrust that she doesn't trust him absolutely to come back
every time. Therefore trust me, he said, and we will get on well and I will accomplish
the work of my will. So I want to give you a number of references on trust and then we
leave it there. Philippians 1, 6, the Lord will finish the job that he started if you
let him. 2 Samuel 22, 3. In him will I trust. Sam 4 verse 5. Sam 5 verse 11. Sam 16 verse
1. Sam 25 verse 2. Sam 62 verse 8. Sam 91 verse 4. And 1 Timothy 4, 10. I want to take a
break there.